et alors Véronique ce soir on commence
par le Mois Molière voilà c'est riche ce
printemps dans les Yvelines on va avoir
un petit peu de concurrence mais c'est
ça qui est bien quand les gens ont le
choix c'est génial alors moi je vais
vous parler donc du Mois Molière qui a
lieu pour la 27e édition au mois de juin
et je voulais vous faire un petit règle
un petit retour en arrière en fait ce
fameux mois Baudière donc il existe
depuis 27 ans il a été initié créé par
Françoise Mazières qui était à l'époque
adjoint au maire Étienne peintre à
Versailles il était donc s'occupait de
la culture et il a eu l'idée de c'était
un foot théâtre c'est un foot théâtre
Françoise il a même pris des coups de
théâtre chez Marcel tu as en cours ou
peut-être potentiel mais je ne vous bref
et donc il a monté ce festival pour la
première fois en 1996 à l'époque c'était
Francis Perrin qui était le directeur du
Montier et il faut aussi se Perrin était
sur une charrette avec sa troupe et
aller à ranguer elle est fulls mais
presque dans dans les rues de Versailles
comme comme Molière faisait comme les
troupes faisaient à l'époque pour
annoncer leur venue et leur spectacle
voilà donc ça et en fait l'idée de
françois de Mazières qui est depuis 2008
maintenant au maire de Versailles et
c'est de promouvoir le renouveau des
spectacles vivants populaires de le
privilégier les jeunes compagnies il y
en a beaucoup qui sont résidences à
Versailles et aussi de
comment dire et l'idée c'est aussi
d'aller vers le public d'aller dans tous
les quartiers d'aller chercher le public
et leur montrer que finalement c'est pas
que sérieux pas que sinistres enfin que
ça peut être drôle voilà c'était être et
musique donc ça c'est dit et qu'est-ce
que ah oui et alors la force de ce
festival c'est qu'en fait c'est
quasiment tout le temps gratuit sauf
quelques fois 2 euros vous voyez ce qui
est pas énorme et je pense que c'est
aussi grâce à un nombre il y a une
centaine de bénévoles qui sont là depuis
le début et c'est ça qui fait la force
et qui permet ce système de gratuite et
pas de secret voilà les bénévoles c'est
dit donc après
les pièces elles vont souvent à Avignon
ou la même françois de Mazières va
chercher des pépites pour nous les
montrer l'année d'après voilà et
donc il y a 25 c'est la 27ème édition ça
fait juste trois fois que je le dis pas
il y A 330 représentations cette
création 1000 comédiens musiciens 62
lieux donc dans Versailles etc et 150000
spectateurs voilà donc parmi ces 330
représentations est-ce que vous avez
repéré des temps forts Véronique comment
vous le savez Mathieu vous êtes trop
forts
alors oui j'ai même un SCO ma chère amie
imaginez-vous que aujourd'hui est sortie
la programmation de ce fameux Mois
Molière donc il y a des temps forts qui
j'ai regardé ce qui est en premier je me
suis pas trop foulé mais bon on n'avez
pas attendre non plus ça va être dans la
cour des grandes écuries qui a lieu
majestueux magique voilà c'est super
alors vous aurez par exemple premier de
juin
cogner une histoire africaine c'est une
création d'Eric Bouvron qui a été
nominée au Molière 2022 pour Laurence
d'Arabie et qui a eu un prix Molière du
théâtre privé pour cavalier en 2018 donc
voilà ce Joséphine Coleman berger je
connais très très bien c'est vrai
on parle tout un peu de la même chose
c'est ça que movie théâtrale en Afrique
subsaharienne guerre contre les
braconniers un drame personnel donc ça
c'est le premier scoop après vous avez
si je relis la page d'avance il n'y a
pas Richard III alors Richard III de
William Shakespeare mis en scène est
jouée par William mezguiche qui est le
fils de son père donc on imagine qu'il a
de kit tenir ce jeune homme donc ça
c'est encore une deux représentation
après vous avez la voix d'or ça vous
parle aussi d'Eric Bubu écrit par
Thibault audinaire c'est deux vedettes
de l'après-guerre qui vit une histoire
d'amour passionnelle et déstrueux
destructrice pas déstructuré un
spectacle musical et
et les conséquences de cette violence
amoureuse sur la famille vont vont être
montrés avec des reconstitutions
beaucoup de chansons et des souvenirs
etc et pour terminer les Fourberies de
Scapin quand j'étais
bref mais après qu'elle ne fut pas ma
joie on regarde on peut plus près alors
s'il met en scène par Anthony manier et
parmi les acteurs de cette création oui
parce que j'ai pas dit c'était des
créations voilà vous aurez les acteurs
des mauvais élèves cette compagnie
horizontale que j'adore avec Elisa
Benito que j'ai déjà reçu en VIP qui est
la fille de Shirley Dino qui les aident
à mettre en scène et il y a elle il y a
Bérénice Caudry Anthony Magnier et
Valérian je sais plus et ils sont juste
extra franchement c'est quelqu'un un peu
réfractaire au théâtre et un peu une
impasse c'est son eux qu'il faut voir
quoi d'accord
je l'affirme haut et fort donc tout ça
au mois de juin
et pour votre deuxième information on
reste à Versailles et vous allez nous
parler esprit et jardin
le week-end prochain 22 23 avril donc
c'est la un événement pour les
passionnés de jardin c'est toute la
journée de 10 à 19h et c'est place de la
cathédrale Saint-Louis sur le parvis les
carrés Saint-Louis et au Potager du Roi
alors bon ça fait 15 ans que ça existe
il y a 70 exposants plein d'animations
etc il y a aussi des nouveautés pour
pour nous attirer en coréen encore ils
ont bien raison alors les nouveautés
qu'est-ce que ça va être un spectacle un
peu médiéval qui s'appelle les Oise
savante ça vous parle cette compagnie
dog trainer en fait ils ont animé des
fêtes médiévales avec un troupeau de
doigts 50
éducateur canin au départ et qui a un
peu bifurqué vers le dressage mais
gentil d'animaux donc ils ont leur chien
leurs oies leurs moutons et là il y aura
un spectacle les oies savantes ça fait
du
malganisation c'est un chien qui va les
garder vous inquiétez pas
il y aura aussi alors une conférence de
Jean-Pierre Thauvin alors je le connais
il est passionnant ce monsieur c'est un
ordithologue qui manque de l'année
l'association naturaliste des Yvelines
et il a une propose une conférence sur
la place des oiseaux en ville et dans
les jardins et de ce qui reste comme
oiseau parce qu'il est référenti ça oui
merci voilà c'était ça que je cherchais
donc voilà après vous aurez aussi une
découverte de Versailles cité-jardin on
vous emmènera faire une rando-conférence
avec des petites histoires sur des lieux
naturels comme le parc Balbi les étang
Gobert des endroits où on va pas
forcément qu'on connaît pas forcément
l'allée des mortes mais la pièce de déçu
etc voilà il y aura un atelier de
décoration végétale un atelier de
tissage végétal un peu comme au
Moyen-Âge décidément excusez-moi je
repère ma voix atelier de rempotage et
emprunte animale etc alors avec un coup
de cœur pour un événement enfin une
attraction que dans une activité comme
on dit je sais pas sur
les beaux arbres les beaux-arts
remarquables
parce que les arbres remarquables
doivent pour être répertoriés classés
comme arbre remarquable à votre corps
les beaux-arts ils sont beaux ils sont
les trouve beaux pointe à la ligne voilà
donc vous avez une appli sur l'appli
Versailles vous avez un parcours qui ont
mis en place justement pour le salon
esprit jardin mais qui qui est
fonctionne dès maintenant vous avez une
quinzaine d'arbres qui ont été
répertoriées comme vous et on vous fait
le l'itinéraire vous avez donc
différents arbres vous avez un petit
côté historique sur chaque arbre on vous
raconte une petite histoire et c'est
bien parce que on les voit pas forcément
alors par exemple vous avez les
cerisiers du Japon en fleurs c'est
splendeur voilà ils sont très beaux
aussi en automne parce que les feuilles
sont des couleurs magnifiques vous avez
quoi d'autre comme magnifique arbres
beaux arbres je crois que j'ai perdu ma
feuille je vais devoir dire de mes mains
le cèdre du Liban de l'école des
konamine vous avez des c'est quand même
dingue d'avoir perdu
toute façon c'est pas en direct
allez voir par vous même voilà vous vous
allez vous débrouiller donc tout ça
esprit et jardin c'est ce weekend
de ce soir si vous voulez by night by
night
problème on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine comme d'habitude ça fait
plaisir